[Musique]
savoir que je suis pas bien un char de
chez le médecin m a dit je suis
intolérant la touchez pas quoi m'a dit
faut que je te tape à un truc que du
lait sans lactose sais pas quoi reçus
chez salah sais quoi du lait d'amande
du lait d'amande droit c'est-à-dire les
errements de raison des mamelles et
fondu les
amène je te promets que j'ai pas envie
de tester ce truc là ça me fait flipper
du lait d'amande j'étais absent mais
j'ai pas confirmé ces essais après tout
les visiteurs ils boivent ça marche et
pas un hipster frais excuse moi tout le
temps ça quand même une dégaine un des
rares sdf qui est sdf depuis un jour
personne n'est dupe un match chiant
tolérant à la tossée ce qu'ils veulent
mais dire les médecins nous un truc se
plaît à mettre la terre assiste en fait
mais raciste ou quoi que tu crois tu
parles ça commence toujours comme ça je
les connais mais comme toi intolérants
au lactose après sont intolérants arabe
intolérants aux juifs ce qu'il en est a
dégainé tâte et eyepet a monté une
application hipster lait d'amande
montrent une application de pronostic à
là ça va cartonner pronostique alain
ouais c'est des pronostics où les gens
et gagne jamais ça veut dire ils parient
pas du coup tu prends pas de péché et du
coup ça là autant pas monter la pluie à
la messale alors arrêtez de tout
analyser ce te plaît arrête de tout
analyser frais arrête tu vas tu viens
halal qui veut du champagne à l'altitude
c'est quoi la prude et pour nos annales
du coup je me casse toi tu m'en souviens
bien avec ta tête là robert robert toi
et moi à faire du business ensemble la
l'épicerie on va la transformer en
bureaux mais c'est tout une épicerie tu
fais ce que tu fais ma gueule frère de
quoi tu me parles si tu veux un conseil
du mandat y tenez puisse recommencer
parle transformée en garage pour qu'on
engage pas ce que c'est que c'est comme
ça tout mandat commencé est toujours pas
le reportage quoi bill gates mark
zuckerberg nagui ils ont tous commencé
dans un garage et tu as vu où ils en
sont maintenant on va en faire un gage
j'ai une boutique dans un scooter garé
il me serait mais tu as une boutique moi
je ne sais pas vraiment juste mon
scooter je sais rien faire avec mon
scooter je sais même pas ce que c'est un
joint de culasse je croyais que ça se
fume et moi c'est quoi ton 3 bougez pas
on va faire du cbd on va faire du cbd ça
cartonne on fait du cbb ça par contre
c'est une bonne idée le message n'est
pas le contraire c'est exactement comme
les voitures sans permis et les bières
sans alcool s'est éclatée contraintes
boubli a aucun risque et je pense que ça
fait mal marché conclu marché conclu 13
ans
[Musique]